nein warum tötest du mich die ganze zeit
warum guckst du die besten weg das hat
nichts zu bedeuten was von nichts gehört
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge sky denn folge
sieben mittlerweile sind wir ja aber
noch zusammen deren produktivität in
personen cod kdh ich gar nicht netten
eindruck
ich finde ich voll gold also eher was
ich gerade mache ich erstmal was du
machst das was ich mache sieht magath
ich mache gerade unsere farben weiter
weil es das ist den grünen ob das denn
ja gut ich baue gerade unser haus so ein
bisschen so eine art unterboden und
darin nach interessant die mit zweiten
boden
das war eine gute sache weil wir
wirklich comedy mit zweiten boden machen
und jetzt bräuchten so ganz war im boden
naja verstehst du nicht diesen humor
jedenfalls haben wir da ja ein bisschen
erde auf unserer plattform gab deswegen
möchte ich die erde retten und die
bahnfahrt vergrößern weil wir in der
letzten folge herausgefunden haben dass
beide dass wir beide immer eine quest
machen müssen und nicht wenn einer die
quest macht oder wie beide zusammen dass
es dann nicht für beide gilt sondern nur
für eine person das heißt ich kann schon
mit den anderen handeln ich habe schon
die neue quest dass ich 64 teile brauche
und er ist immer noch bei der alten
quest und ja deswegen möchte ich das ein
bisschen wenn ihr fertig werden
überhaupt
es war kann ich viele quest es überhaupt
werden also ich am anfang dachte ich zu
helfen
was sollen wir denn jetzt machen so nach
dem motto aber mittlerweile ist echt so
hiermann hier kann man noch eine quest
machen weil man ist jetzt echt ein
bisschen freier als bei sky blogs kelber
hat man auch so die freiheit dass man so
sagen kann ich mache erst des ministers
aber hier ist jetzt gerade da denke ich
mir so
ich bin dahin gegangen der typ meinte
sogar witze quest machen oder wird es
mit den hier so ein bisschen handeln
oder witz mit dem reden oder von dem was
machen für wen zum rollenspiel so was
will man so als nächstes mal so frei
dass man sich das nicht aussuchen kann
das ist echt so ich fühle mich echt
sowie in einem staat im staat auf der
fliegenden insel mit zwei bewohnern
nein so von vom von der staatsregierung
auf nfc staatsideologie essen level hast
du eigentlich 55 bis auto was machst du
jetzt schon wieder überzog zu den
arbeitsplatz ja warum schickst du mich
denn jetzt an
warum
veronique man was machst du viel
hässliches ding hin alter ich will doch
nur du hast mich gar nicht zu doch warum
fahren vergrößern aber trotzdem herzlich
will die erde retten die hier ist können
die hersteller nach herstellen und das
gibt bewies das muss ja mal wieder
aufnehmen bei mir kommt zurzeit die
folgen die teams vor einer woche
gebracht haben
guck mal zu mir rüber
hilfe ich sehe keine monster s ball
wie sehe ich nicht auf die entfernung
muss aber gleichzeitig peter baum fahren
ja vier rotten flesh alter
der schulhof etwas mit ihm kollidiert
ist so schlau erwarte ich jetzt wieder
steine herunter so jetzt
wie kann denn das sein das ist ja alles
korrekt
aha
ja fertig dazu kommen
es ist alles so wie vorher jetzt gerade
die marke spenden so
mit
er hätte ja dann lasst unser bett
mainboard stellen
auf diese höhe hier so dass man einfach
normal reinlegen durch höhen bleibt
warum stört testen
okay es geht mit warum hast du mich denn
jetzt wieder getötet weil test centers
bonn
ich wollte so gesetzten ab so schlimm
wäre ein erhöhte dich selber hab ich
will ich will etwas produktives hier
machen und immer wichtig so damit zum
tod der opfer hat
du musst übrigens wieder dich im game 1
0 machen
das macht
bei euch gemacht
gerade macht das warum warum warum warum
lebst du noch die probleme oder was hast
du gerade
warum liebst du bist was hast du gerade
10 bis 4 grad
ich bin komisch nein warum tötest du
mich die ganze zeit zu die betten lag
das hat nichts zu bedeuten
das war nichts gehört ich wollte das
nicht mehr response system of response
übe ich freue mich gerade auf der du
bist einfach dumm
das spiel mag dich nicht und das zu
recht so wo sind denn jetzt die betten
was soll diese komischen plättchen auf
dem server so wir müssen jetzt was musst
du denn jetzt eigentlich machen ich du
bist immer noch deiner quester ne
scheiße erwarte jetzt gemacht haben
nicht schlau
warum tötest du mich letztes mal bringt
doch selber runter alters testen
es geht nicht darum jedes nicht man töte
dich selber wenn du das testen willst
mir ist das scheißegal ich sterbe ja
nicht außer wenn du mich tötet kohle
kohle kohle
ich brauch stückchen stückchen stückchen
mehr so viele von diesen komischen namen
machte so jetzt kommt ein kleiner test
also sollte dich selber warum immer ich
ja sicher auf
einen apfel
man jetzt wachsen die bäume gleich ein
riesending
warum nimmst du mir denn jetzt die
steine weg wird wollte auch haben junge
mann definitiv tronic warum warte warte
warte weiter kommt schon warum waren die
aufnahme ab alter warum geht es nicht
junge halt die schnauze jetzt noch
alleine
ja ich habe schon fest warum ging das
nicht schon von einem stunde gesagt ja
aber ich habe deinen sport eingesetzt so
geht es nicht
guck mal ich hab mein holz warte ich
eben die quester von der rolle können
wir einmal zu einem perfekten leben wenn
wir irgendwas testen willst dann teste
das mit dir selber oder springen selber
irgendwo runter und teste das nicht mehr
viele teile sie auch sagte sinn machen
würde sagt roll oder immer vor in die
gebiete du brauchst irgendwas und auf
einmal kommt eine an töte dich dass ein
test ob die töten konnte ich werde desto
dritten response wenn ich da hinten
respawnen dann macht es auch keinen sinn
oder bekommen grasbrook bekommen die
scheiße ist ja dass ich jetzt im gras
verkaufen wir beide von dem nutzen
machen werden teilen müssen du bist
immer so ich werde die ganze dient was
ich werde ganz sind getötet
was ja auch nicht schlimm ist gericht
weil es für mich als kind zählt ja ist
doch scheißegal trotzdem nervt das so
muss ein gibt unsere
da sie sowohl machen müssen dass auf
jeden fall mit ich wollte dir einen spot
machen auf einem einzelnen blog warum
machst du das du so spaß zum testen wenn
jedoch heraus kommen wir zum beispiel
wenn ich irgendwie drauf lassen würden
was zum abschluss des projekts oder
später einen thron aber nein ich darf
ich bei dir testen das heißt es geht
dann auch man kann nicht auf half dingen
dann sagst daran wahrscheinlich
ich weiß es nicht ich war kein unnützes
wissen wie du alter mann sonst kommen
die verspätet an
so ich mache jetzt einfach hier diese
komische raesfeld an die das wächst der
dann nicht wenn du mich dass sie direkt
finden beträgt
so ist zwar haben wir immer noch selber
ist ob der counter den den werde ich nie
wieder einholen können nein ich brauche
hier sogar noch einmal krank bist du
drin und was machst du denn da hat man
etwas produktives hier
hallo ich habe gerade die monster fragen
ist die tipps die ganze zeit und willst
testen ob ichs vorne
tja und ist wichtig du hast innerhalb
von zwölf minuten die wende
ich richte meinen respekt und meine
sachen gesammelt
ich habe meine das lister kam kommen
können ganze 1 von 2
vielleicht habe ich auch das ganze hab
ich gesammelt habe ich eins und zwei und
bauen fehlt mir noch zwei mal an der box
gelegt in die kiste wenn du das willst
an flash gehen wenn du brauchst jetzt
fehlen nur noch die alte welt so machen
müssen
ach so hättest du dir deine sachen
gelegentlich auch gehabt quasi jackson
ja aber die wiesn zu verdecken inventar
und du musst ja nach dem abgeben
hast du noch bei 1 291 komplett ab
okay das heißt er werde nicht festmachen
müssen uns erstmal auf dem gleichen
stand kommen konnte das heißt ich
brauche es nur noch ich habe schon 45
das heißt ich brauche noch 19
ich habe zehn finger noch 9
wer sagt dass jeder es gebe damit ihre
frechen standpunkt sind ist es wichtig
die ich mit mir das viel interessanter
weil wegen der unterschiedlichen festes
arbeiten dann was du willst nicht
nachgegeben hat vorhin weil du was also
weiter bist und dann was danach gesagt
und ich meine sachen geben habe sind
westen nicht so weit wollten element
deine sachen gegeben
ich habe vorhin als du irgendwas gefehlt
wie die quest das habe ich dir geben
die letzten beiden teams nein doch nein
doch gewicht gemacht habe ich dir
gelassen damit die abgeben kann sein
weil deutschland voller stars
nachzuschauen in folge 6 koch doch
schreibt sie die kommentare hätten
irgendwie glaube ich eigentlich ende
2002 kampagne geben wenn zum beispiel
mich nicht eingesammelt damit er das
dorf hätten wir hab ich gesagt so was
wie mach lieber du für ein sicheres
gesagt ach so ja gut nein nein nein die
habe ich nie habe ich eingesammelt von
dem skelett da waren ja oben dabei ich
habe es absichtlich nicht eingesammelt
damit du sie einsamen kannst dann wären
wir nein ich habe direkt eingesammelt
jetzt auch so nicht einsammeln können
weil du viel zu langsam gewesen wäre
lüge so wenn wir jetzt erfahren baum
wollen das heißt ich muss hier was
hängen ja gut
st
ich musste einen block nach kempen
wenn ich verloren habe merkt das schon
blöd
es war eine sinnvolle investition hallo
hier muss allerdings block in der hier
dann kommt hier die absperrung bewirken
so
zack zack zack zack zack
hier muss keine absperrung rum aber hier
damit der chronik da nicht immer runter
fällt ja
nicht so viel dafür hier noch der
komiker shops immer wenn er ja immer
schon mal immer schubst die chance mich
immer ich hätte an diesem ort von feed
the beast und dies macht das wenn man
zum beispiel keinen schein hat dass die
nächsten automatische und inventar rein
rücken inventory tricks ja genau das war
praktisch
so jetzt brauchen wir noch wasser und
dann ist das schon alles relativ gut
eingehängt ich mache noch eine wand
hinter mit nicht immer so monz
herunterfallen ja man ja auch gerade so
eine art wand wenn ihr schon gesehen
wehrt sich schon mal nicht gut an für
mich da fand ich noch welche
ich würde sagen dass sie irgendwie
hersteller bekommen könnten den netten
eintauscht glaube nicht einzig wirklich
nicht
noch diesen einen blöden knochen nur
einen einzigen noch ein einzel
die verkaufs wertvoll es wird wieder
nach sehr gut weiß noch andere folge
angefangen hast ich säge hat positive
sind auch bei 17 minuten aber ich möchte
ganz kurz nach diesen weg jetzt weiter
bauen was wenn du hier bist ist dann die
familie aber laufen auf das ja ja nein
oder doch haben wieder irgendwie drei
reihen voll mit stacks wasser hin dass
ich mich komplett mit wasser um fließend
umflossen haben dass sie die geile
ausfindig haben wir zwei oder mehr
wir brauchen keine ahnung haben wir eine
quälerei nicht
ich glaube nicht einfach bloß dass kein
krieg wieder hochgeht themen die bei
dicken etwas wasser so schön scheiße
wirklich keine quelle wasser wir haben
das nur bei dem generator glaub ich okay
da ein wasser
schau mal nach wir irgendwann wasser
wenn das falsch gebaut von mir factory
also hier haben ihren höhlen portal the
portal an diesem abend wo die spur von
wasser aber nicht immer einer kiste was
oder beim chor ist in rage oder irgend
sowas kommt entscheide da haben wir eins
aber erst mal einen eimer wenn ich
irgendwie handeln oder so deswegen haben
wir haben nicht mal ein eimer wie würden
wir das hier platzieren wollen und er
einmal conny ja wenn wir handeln können
oder so kriegen wir vielleicht einmal
es waren einmal vielleicht regenwasser
einer transportfirma ein aufnahmestopp
vielleicht gleich gleichmäßig so tut mir
leid gras aber in detroit geboren aber
nicht
dann haben wir noch 13 übrig brauchst du
dann bäume machen können die bäume lasse
ich dir einfach für dich dann wegen
deiner kreisblatt er praktisch uhr
ich verstehe nicht was ist denn bei ford
ist es vielleicht schlimm wenn man das
ist ja weil erstens die pilzsuppe das
heiße bauherrenpreis java war wieso dann
verrottetes fleisch was ist so schlimm
daran wenn man das ist was heißt denn
dies hunger allerdings vergisst hunger
krieg was heißt dass krieg sommer ja das
hat aber kein nachteil ich kann sprinten
ja du verlierst im prinzip ist es egal
im prinzip was wir haben keine fackeln
dabei der pilzköpfe monster und auch ein
kritisch passt einfach das sehr gut auch
willi daume geeignet ich schaff das
schon am besten schräg gegenüber zu
schlagen man recruiters trotha inversion
skelett aber das kommt jetzt auch zu mir
hin
brauchst du noch knochen er ein
vielleicht dann holen weiß noch nicht
weiß nicht vielleicht nicht
unterstützend nicht mit gummi scheißegal
nur etwa dass ein kripomann kontakt so
gut
das abfackeln was wenn es gelingt das
wird sicher die bauen
irgendwas irgendwo im keller oder so er
gut freunde da muss ich sagen machen wir
eben aufnahmestopp wenn es euch gefallen
hat durch die gerne einen daumen hoch da
lassen könnte mir auch oder uns
weiterhin in die kommentare schreiben
wenn ihr wisst ob irgendein wassereimer
haben oder ob wir den irgendwie verlegt
haben oder bekommen tauschen können oder
ja genau oder in welche anderen sachen
abwägen was tauschen können
und sowas alles halt also daher sind wir
auf jeden fall mit einem auge immer bei
den kommentaren und damit sagen wie man
es in der nächsten folge morgen wieder
bei ca